hello everyone and welcome to the
highlight shop class chess international
my name is Santa Barbara Hyman and I'm
going to take you to the key moments of
day four first of all congratulations to
Fabiana Khurana for defeating linear
Dominguez and congratulations to Levon
Aronian for defeating Alexander Chris
cheek and qualified to the semi-finals
both these matches were very exciting
and absolutely abiders they all came
down to the very last game had some very
entertaining moments some clutch
victories you know the way this
tournament is named so let's jump right
into it to the action and check out what
happened in day four so let's start with
the match between Levon Aronian and
Alexander Christian so coming into the
day Levon Aronian had a two point lead
over Alexander Christian after winning
that clutch victory of Queen versus rook
which you can check out in my previous
video so it's a great success with the
white pieces and it looks like he had a
slight edge in a position but on move 22
after roxie to c5 finding lemon onion
finding the correct move and equalizing
the position so just exchanging
everything the rest of the game is not
important we reach an opposite color
picture position so just to show you
what happened so just a repetition and
the game ends and so this game was not
the most entertaining one so just to
show you how the day started so let's
move on to our second game so Alexander
grace chick won this game with the black
pieces so let's go to our key moment on
move xx so Bishop e7 was played the last
move so the Queen goes to a 5 b6 Levon
Aronian grabs this very dangerous
looking pawn and there is this amazing
resource in the position the point is
this Knight cannot be touched because
after take check and the queen is gone
so instead Bishop c4 was played so
there's another key moment in this game
so I will just walk you through the
moves to that point so before this so
this position it's a little crazy but
black is up material so it's a matter of
technique but the game does get
kind of messy because that's a quick
game and Alexander Grichuk is notorious
for its time trouble so at some point
LaVon gets some chances to actually save
the game so let's move on to our next
key moment and a rugby 594 so this was a
key moment because Knight a5 was
actually a mistake and white needs to
take this pawn and try to defend this
position instead he goes Knight a5 but
unfortunately he is mad with 96 and now
the Rope doesn't have a very good square
it's about you to defend everyone so he
is forced to take this and this position
is lost because this Knight is just too
far away from this one to defend the
pawn so this b6 pound will fall and not
too many difficulties for blacks to
convert this so let's just see how this
game ended ended quite quickly and the
problem with this Knight is it gets
cornered and gets dominated so this
route will give a check King go to f4
and black can just start collecting the
spots
so I send a grecian wins the second game
and now the score is there's a 1-point
difference between the players so let's
move on to our third game so third game
was and this game could have ended in a
drop but unfortunately because some
mention of this poor time management
alexander Grichuk had ten seconds on his
clock so after he's playing with the
white pieces after Queen v3 before he
immediately captures back and now the
trick is that Quincy one queen bee and
there's no way to defend this Knight to
defend this bishop so it's just losing a
piece and I will show you what the
difference was once I show you what
happened in the game here and just takes
and resigns because it's also
unstoppable mate and there is no way to
check so if we go back to this moment
Quincy fire at Quincy man excuse me is
not possible here because of Queen d5 so
if you take I will take your bishop
and before it's a nice trick and white
should have played King jutsu to get out
of this and the game should have ended
in a drop and unfortunately that cost
him the game so now once again the
difference is two points so let's take a
look at our game tent so this one
actually the result didn't really matter
too much as grace Chuck explained
because he still needed to win a clutch
game and to make a draw to have a chance
to win this match
so two point difference or three point
different would have mattered he still
needed to score one half in the neck
clutch games next two clutch games
because win in the round eleven and
twelve is worth three points and draw is
one and a half and if you and the
tiebreaks are your amount of clutch
points you have so winning around eleven
is worth more than the winning round six
even though both of them are clutch
games because five and six rounds yield
two points whereas eleven and twelve
yields three points it's a bit of a
complicated system but it makes for
entertaining chests
all right so let's move on to this game
because it also had some important
moments so this was a marathon game it
lasted or 112 moves so let's go to our
key moments so in this position Chris
chick has a knight and three pounds for
rook so they should be winning but some
missed opportunities so here he actually
had this really incredible win of going
d3 d2 sacrificing this guy and checking
and now a2 and actually it's really
incredible because there's no way to
stop this fun even though the king is
close you cannot get close to the pawn
the rook cannot get close to the pawn
and this pawn is just simply going to
quit if the rook goes to b8 we can
simply play King a seven and again no
way to stop this fun so this would have
been an incredible way of finishing the
game but again are very difficult to do
with the very little time on the clock
so instead there's actually another key
moment in this game instead let's go to
let's go forward a few moves
so he decides to give up this pawn and
he goes knight c6 and this is a mistake
because what he needs to do he has to
play King before put a knight on v3 and
start pushing the spawns to avoid a
blockade and actually Lebanon young
finds a great way of defending this and
I this is very instructive let's take a
look at how he did it
system so now if the rook goes and that
goes behind and not the rook simply just
pins this night and it's impossible to
make progress because c3 we're simply
going to take very happily and this is
going to be a drum and if not sit to
read then d3 the now it's a blockade so
King before was play it so again pinning
the rook beginning the night and just
back and forth so I mean they're just
repeating at this point so not a lot of
progress is being made so we do see the
blockade so it looks like blogg made
some kind of progress but now this
pumpkin never moved because this plan is
just forever hanging so just back and
forth and just giving up the rook for
the two pawns and making it wrong so now
we reach the clutch portion of the of
the match and as I mentioned brick needs
to win on a draw game so he's in a
must-win situation and Aronian is of
course very happy with to draw so he's
in a more comfortable position but
there's a reason why this tournament is
called clash chess because I likes under
grace check spoiler alert clutch player
wins the next game and evens out the
match basically so actually this game is
very entertaining okay so let's get
started so grace Chuck is with the right
pieces so he just goes all out from the
beginning so starting with a quiet
nimnim
and just going for it
Bishop g5 of course cannot take because
of mate
my my arrow didn't go all the way it
made on 87 so queen h5 is play it now g4
26 rook g1 just getting ready for this
attack and not you five just blowing the
position wide open so it takes Bishop f5
and Bishop goes back pinning and now he
plays there should be someone going for
the material which may be a practical
decision but Bishop h6 was very strong
and a position it just gets crazy
the entrance is right is winning it's
hard to can their narrow it down why
white is winning because if you take on
g7 I take here and check and super messy
crazy position but instead he goes
Bishop e7 he grabs the exchange and
again the position starts to get a
little messy because even though you're
up to exchange your king is weak there's
you know the bishop here is very
annoying and the pawn on d5 is an
impressive fondo so he just keeps
pushing the pawn and now we're entered
this endgame on the same game is not
simple at all so he decides to exchange
the rooks because that rook is super
annoying bringing the King so everything
is very logical and this is another key
moment in the game because he finds this
incredible night of five move and that
becomes impossible to defend everyone so
for example if you take so in the game
night v6 was played we'll come back to
that everyone is hanging
if tries to let's say move the bishop
somewhere then rook t6 again some puns
are falling so not a lot of good options
for blacks eight plays Knight b6 takes a
pawn repeats takes a bishop and we
already saw how the rook dominates the
night and this is not even close and the
pawns are just rolling and the game is
over amazing victory by Alex and Chris
your clutch victory so it all came down
to the
Ronde both players needed to win this
game to to qualify to the semi-final so
muslin situation and from my
introduction you know what happened in
this game but still let's take a look
because the finish of this game was
incredible amazing tactics by Levon
Aronian and you know when you win a
clutch clutch game a cleric there this
is how you want to end things castle and
when we look at the position right away
we see this 96 ideas but you know you
have to make it work at the right moment
and unfortunately for Greece Turkey
plays Rick ft8
falling right for it the Queen moves so
unfortunately for the Queen cannot stay
on this diagonal so has to move away
from the action and now 96 counts so
everyone is hanging again so there is no
you know everyone is defended but there
comes we should be seven and a rook
lifts and this checkmate is unstoppable
if the Queen moves for example so after
Roxy seven Christian resigned allowing
his opponent to qualify to the
semi-finals so an amazing finish an
amazing match and once again
congratulations to Levon Aronian
what a way to finish the day let's move
on to our next match the match between
two Americans by Briana Khurana and
linear Dominguez so they played in the
first edition of clutch chess if you
follow that in the first match and that
wasn't close at all as we talked about
it domingus only scored one victory but
this time around things were different
it was a lot closer match so today this
match was very intense because in the
first four games there are four decisive
results and all four games were won with
the black pieces which is not something
we hear very often especially not at the
very highest level so let's get started
so Fabiana starts with the white pieces
and he again comes to he enters the day
with the lead over his opponent and to
let's takes the same throughout the day
because well not throughout the day
until the clashes because all four games
and the decisively so let's get started
with our
for this game let's go to move 34 or
Fabiana play this mistake King Gator
instead he should go Queen d7 exchange
Queens and look for chances in this
rockin game instead he plays King gay to
d6 and that's the same thing here except
now on the night stay on the board and
he doesn't get a pawn back so the rest
is a matter of technique and linear
played really well so let's take a look
at how he converted and as we see the
spawns ours falling because with the
knight on the board and this night being
dominated by the rook becomes very hard
to defend the King side and there's too
many pawns and he can't just sacrifice
his phone and he can't just sacrifice
his night for the pawn and just has too
much material on this other side of the
board and the game is over so nice
victory with the black pieces so in this
position which derives from a caro-kann
and this is a opening that Fabiano has
been using in this match quite
successfully you said the first game
where he just got destroyed there's no
chance one-sided game linear just beat
him so easily
and after that he recovered and his
opening has been holding up quite well
so he plays d4 sacrificing this pawn and
the reason I'm saying sacrificing is
because of course he can take it back
but he chooses not to he activates his
rook
it's a rook c5 is played but there's a
great example of good night versus a bad
bishop and we're going to see how he
improves his position just goes after
all the puns and the problem for white
is once he loses one pawn a lot of the
pawns are gonna hang so if we look at
this position how many of these pawns
are hanging and this game ended in like
five six moves g6 if you look at this
bishop this bishop is not a happy piece
and again white cannot hang on to all
the puns
rook t8 very nice move trading down into
a bishop versus night and game and here
actually linear resigned because if King
has to go after this pawn and in the
meantime the King will come take all
this pawns with the night and he's just
going to lose his entire Quinn site and
you know no not really point of keeping
this game going so let's take a look at
the very next game so now the score is
the same there's a three-point
difference between the players but now
Dominguez comes back and wins with the
black pieces and this one was actually a
very pretty way because so because
fabiana's would smoke himself basically
so we have this position where a black
is doing obviously really well another
example of good night versus a bad
Bishop as in the other one and this time
line here is the one with the good night
because this night can hop around you
know go here at like this pawn make
things uncomfortable for white whereas
this Bishop is really restricted so here
actually Bishop III needs to be played
because this endgame is a drop because
King f5 will be mad with King f3 and now
we can just move forever like this white
will simply wait for the King to go to
f5 to meet it with King after him
instead he blundered with King g2 and
after King f6 is simply in a zigzag
because if he plays King f3 for example
King j5 and now there is no move for
white because the King moves if the King
moves this King comes in if the bishop
moves somewhere it will be taken and the
King will come in from the other side so
King f6 a really nice subtle move but
just the simple looks like this just no
moves so this is the position so King
after King f6 and Bishop e3 again runs
into King f5 if King f3 we already saw
this position and if the bishop decides
to move packed and well you cannot go
here it was the palm would hang so you
have to go to the other side and that
the King comes in and now the knight
will go around and just collect all the
parts in the desk right so this is why
we don't put our pants on the same call
our bishop so again the gap narrows
there's a 2-point difference and now
next Fabiano has the black pieces so
let's take a look at what happened in
Game four the final game before class
chess so let's jump to move 28 so we can
see that Dominguez is doing quite well
this postponed on b7 is really annoying
this Knights on c5 looks like a very
nice dominating position but he made
some mistake with Queen e4 and
immediately h3 weakening this King to 3d
to have five distracting the Queen
taking the pawn distracting the Queen
from defending the pawn and the rock
will come to have seven and we're going
to see this light squares might not be
defendable so he takes the pawn which
looks like a reasonable move but now
Knight f3 25 and with Ace King he's in a
lot of trouble so night before attacking
the Queen the Queen moves twin h5 and a
very nice finish to the game and resigns
because if King h3 and Queen h5 is made
and if King g5 then rocky 5 is checkmate
so very unfortunate for linear and so
here now they're going to class chess
with a three-point difference so very
similar to the Greek situation linear
needs to win one game and make a draw in
the next one too to be able to qualify
to the semis so in this position white
coast e6 and again knowing your route
and games as I mentioned before can you
have six which is a bit of a strange
move because it allows this really nice
chance for Y to put the route behind but
now
Fabiana makes the error would rule t3 or
it needs to start going with the king
and after rookie 5
if you go back then route e5 check again
cutting the King off so instead he goes
after this one but of course this is
great resource of going for defending
this pawn and just simply bringing the
canyon and there's just no way to make
progress so for example if rook g5
I can already make a draw with this
simple move and this pawn is just gone
rook will come behind and we'll take it
so instead rook f8 was played
so some back-and-forth and the game ends
in a king and fondant game okay so they
repeat a few times to make a drop and as
you at some point the answerer was
mentioning that you can't think of a
strong player who hasn't lost their
superior rügen gains I think at some
point maybe he was getting for it that
Fabiano might make some kind of a
mistake and end up in the last king and
town and game but of course is very
strong player and that wasn't gonna
happen so let's jump into our very last
game linear Dominguez with the white
pieces like an Armageddon game basically
you know the Ord I must win situation
another choral concert the caro-kann had
really well did a very good job for
Fabiano so queen hy was played so we
reach this position where white is up
upon but black holes quite comfortably
so Rakosi c4 and we realized this queen
is a very misplaced piece cannot really
move back because you can just simply
take the pot and when the action is only
on one side of the port the night
usually is much better than the bishop
because the bishops are very good when
things are happening on both sides
because they can attack both sides and
the knight can become limited but on one
side of the board the night can really
dominate a bishop look c1 so we do a few
trades and the game ends in a repetition
so at some at this point
Dominguez realized there isn't much to
do there isn't a lot of material on the
board and just decided to settle for a
draw which allowed Fabian a corona to
advance to the semi-finals so again
congratulations to both players of
Fabiano Khurana will be facing off
against Wesley so while we're gonna have
a super exciting match between Magnus
Carlsen Devin or onion the number one
player in the world the world champion
and former longtime number to play 11
our onion a lot of people who are
looking really looking forward to World
Championship match between the two
players but that hasn't happened so far
and of course this is a match that we
always look forward to so tomorrow
actually is going to be a day off and
games are going to resume on Thursday so
make sure you are checking them out
if you want to look through this game's
more thoroughly check them on of the USS
chips and otherwise make sure you're
tuning in on Thursday at monkey
essential for the semi-finals